hey guys it's Joanna here i'm currently
in singapore attending the influence
asia award show i've just woken up i'm
really excited and i want to share with
you my 8 minute
fat burning bed workout so if you're a
frequent traveler and you need a quick
workout which can be done in your hotel
room this is the workout for you or if
you live with someone else and you
prefer to work out from the comfort of
your own room
you can do this workout as well it's
only eight minutes long five exercises
targeting your entire body
it won't boost your metabolism you're
gonna feel really good we will be
burning calories and you will also feel
really energized okay so you can either
do this workout in the morning or in the
evening 5 exercises 45 seconds each and
we'll move on to the next workout
without any rest
so get your body ready and let's work
out together so guys I'm going to set my
timer and we'll start with the first
workout which is squats Tom and I want
you to start by kneeling on the bed okay
so get up onto your bed kneel and we
want to get into a half squat and that's
it okay I'm back down to kneeling
alright so get your body ready
eight more seconds to go and this will
be working on your legs your bombs and
your thighs alright let's go three
seconds and up into a half squat down
okay that's it up and down nice okay the
unstable surface of the bed will
actually make this workout more
challenging and you will engage your
core okay good if you feel comfortable
if you feel that you know what my bed is
not holding well you can of course do it
on the floor with the same movement so
get into a kneeling position and get up
only to a half squat that will really
target your butt and get your heart rate
up and really work on your
all right good keep going up and down
new and down good few more seconds and
we want to get into wipe to never push
up okay so at the edge of the bed why
push up jump to never good ahh
and dump this is a really good workout
to focus on the chest and also your
tricep hold narrow push ah again total
body workout in a short time good you're
going white - namo nuts
beginners if you find this difficult you
can use the wall as well
nice why push narrow or you can take it
step okay choose good go wide narrow
keep your core tight alright
elevated lunge right leg up left leg as
far forward as you can and just support
and just lunch down deep lunge and up
good so by bringing your leg up you will
really be focusing on your left leg and
work your entire left nice and your back
let's just do one side and we will do
the other side for the second side okay
good well my heart is pumping my energy
is up
I'm feeling really good and I'm ready to
start my day after this keep going ten
seconds left and we want to get into
bicycle crunches after this good lunch
down up down and up good sit at the cone
over there right down and cross over it
down up yeah ah good lower yourself and
cross cross good lower and cross that's
it nice bring yourself down cross what
breathe out as you come up very nice
nice this will really work on your acts
your core and give you a title stronger
core and also your hip flexor nice kick
going boom straight legs point cross
good very nice twist twist and look the
opposite side nice and now the five face
workout just lie down get up and jump
good lie down punch up with the ABS jump
lie down all the way crunch up jump
whoa let's get our total body workout
done this morning before we start our
day good
like down extend up jump extend crunch
up jump nice keep going right through
the ABS jump a small hop is good or if
you want to you can really bust and jump
do more what and after this you will get
a one-minute break rest for one minute
and keep yourself hydrated okay so guys
if you have not heard about it I have
been collaborating with the National
Academy of Sports Medicine and a SM to
offer you guys that the opportunity to
take your first step into the fitness
industry okay I got myself certified as
a personal trainer seven years ago and
it is one of the best decisions I've
ever made so if you have considered on
becoming a personal trainer because you
really want to impact other people's
lives and help them to lead a healthier
and happier life then I would say take
this step and try out their 14-day free
trial for their online personal training
costs okay take this step start the new
year feeling really good and you never
know this might be the career path for
you I've learned so much from you guys
ten seconds left and I want to give back
and so I think this is a great
opportunity link and more information is
in my description box and let's do squat
stop let's go up
down nice no break no rest
keep it low up and down up and down we
want to work up a whole bed because okay
like I say the unstable surface will
really make you and get your core even
more and they will force all your
muscles to work even harder good up and
down this is real legs tight on the spot
single spot out okay and get your car
look straight ahead you do not want to
be slouching forward
all right up and down good woof three
more seconds and wife to never push up
let's get one touch now your ops in good
again
you can take a step out don't take a
step in and down okay you can help tip
confidence then jump out and in good
go as low as you can type in your core
keep your chest open and really work
those chest and tricep muscles and also
your shoulders good up and push it in
Nice keep going the throw down will be
elevated lunch on your wife Nick good so
left leg up step as far forward okay
let's get lunch down and up you really
just need a small space to do all this
work out okay they are very effective
very efficient and you will be saving
lots of time by not taking any breaks
and because you don't take any break
that's when your heart rate will really
go up and you will start be burning for
your stuff burning calories good keep
going your right leg working go low and
really squeeze your bum as you come up
nice next back to bicycle crunches few
more last one and one more up whoa let's
go bicycle crunches remember down corner
okay nice twist up really close all the
way up and go as low as you can and feel
the surface feel your core working and
doing the work good
please nice all right
elbows to me elbow to knee OOP breathe
nice go get going guys this is a second
last workout only eight minutes you're
almost done
five more seconds last one
and all the way down crunch up and jump
okay all the way down crunch up and
burst nice all the way down up burst
good
engage your core muscle and burst up
whoo oh my god you never knew your bed
couldn't make it work
really hot did you up keep going do more
come on 50 seconds left do feels like
it's it's nothing compared to what we
have done last one okay just give me one
more let's go
whoa cool down well done awesome awesome
job whoa I need to breathe catch my
breath and I'm ready to start my day
okay
really well done beginners if you find
this to be a challenge to what you can
do is do the workout for 30 seconds and
take a 15 seconds rest okay and as you
progress you want to increase other
workout time
reduce the rest type okay if if you want
to repeat this workout again of course
you can you can do this video once more
and repeat another two more sets so
start the day feeling really good or if
you can't fit it in the morning and your
day knowing that you have done something
I believe that short workout is better
than no workout so if you enjoy this
workout keep doing it and be sure to
like this video and share it with your
friends as well okay all the best I'm
really proud of you guys and just keep
moving towards the direction that you
want for yourself and keep you updated
in your fitness progress
lots of love